row after row of fresh Graves Wagner
mercenaries killed in the last few
months most presumably in the
blood-soaked soil around bakmut and
solidar where Wagner Fighters have led
Russia's offensive and died Ukraine says
like cannon fodder
boss yevgeni pregosian has not been shy
about his losses releasing video of
himself surveying body bags behind the
front lines around New Year
and now some of them are home
we didn't think the guards would let us
in but Russia never fails to surprise
so many freshly dug Graves and a lot of
men in balaclavas who we can't show you
does make you wonder how many more of
these there will be when the battle for
bakmut is finally over and I guess it's
also no wonder that Wagner is having so
many problems recruiting a next round of
prisoners from Russian jails given the
fact that the word has got back to them
that
your chances of returning alive are
pretty slim
gaussian recruiting in prisons last year
the video appearing in September when he
was still barely public as Wagner's boss
since then he's become quite the
battlefield Commander his PR machine
pumping Out video From The Trenches
troops have openly criticized the head
of the army Valerie garasimov and there
is speculation denied by the Kremlin
that garasimov's recent appointment to
run things in Ukraine is an attempt to
keep the ever more outspoken pregosian
in his place
molcano in southern Russia would be an
utterly unremarkable place if it weren't
for the fact that Wagner has long had
its training base here
a run-down Russian village cats on roofs
and battered ladders the thinking here
on why Russia's in Ukraine is not all
that sophisticated
foreign
what about Ukraine what about their
democracy if they want democracy
shouldn't they have it
foreign
has just built a chapel near malkina to
house the urns of cremated Fighters
it's a strange Stark building a reminder
from the road as we pass of the
slaughter in Ukraine and the Shady
forces fighting there
Diana McNay Sky News malkina Russia